[Music]
I'm in Jerusalem and I'm searching for
ecstasy
my search is for the Nana a small sect
of highly religious Jews who themselves
are dedicated to the search for
spiritual ecstasy religion as I knew it
was a childhood battle against boredom
fidgeting in the face of archaic text
but in Jerusalem religion can be more
like the mists spent nights of my youth
a god rave right in the middle of the
streets a full-on yarmulke flapping nana
dance party reverberating through the
ancient Jerusalem stone
like 5 o'clock for the first afternoon
people are kind of dying to go home from
work on the way back from the shops joy
forgot my son since the Happy House in
my old Manchester clubs people weren't
this happy without a little help to
clarify what's going on here I asked a
professor of theology an ecstatic
religious experience is an experience in
which an individual feels that they have
sort of left themselves and have become
one with the universe or God they kind
of outside of themselves and in
connection with something much bigger
than themselves
it exists in almost every religious and
spiritual tradition it can take lots of
shapes and forms and for some people
when they see others pull up in the
spirit it looks kind of crazy
so this is what you like to do on a
Thursday afternoon not every afternoon
actually every afternoon for sure but is
everyone just feeling good because of
the music and faith or do you kind of
augment that with some substances as
well are you guys tripping we don't take
anything I think you don't need all
these substances you know the nanaka
followers of the 19th century rabbi
nachman of breslov and his 20th century
follower rabbi Odessa as a Hasidic Jew
rabbi nachman taught his followers to
observe the traditional dietary
restriction of cash rods and grow the
hair at the corners of their heads but
also encourage them to clap sing and
dance during their prayers to bring them
closer to God there's a disconnection
between your heart and your head and
this connects it together when you start
dancing you know this action it connects
everything together
hmm I'm still skeptical
[Music]